[Musique]
soyez les bienvenus cher qu'à les
spectateurs pour l'interview qui nous
réunit avec le président de la
république algérienne démocratique et
populaire à ce monsieur abdel majid
teboul monsieur le président soyez le
bienvenu sur hergé je vous remercie
l'algérie fait aujourd'hui le premier
anniversaire d'un irakien exceptionnel
et inédit de par son pacifisme et de ce
qu'il a accompli jusqu'ici vous l'avait
qualifié monsieur le président à
plusieurs occasions de béni comme
moubarak m'a dit qu'est ce qui a été
réalisé par se dire actes après un an
mobilisation et qu'est ce qui n'a pas
encore été réalisé c'est un miracle
bénie par excellence je le dis en
connaissance de ce qui allait arriver à
l'état algérien l'état a failli
s'effondrer perdre ses institutions
il était même sur le point d'entrer dans
le programme de ce qu'ils voulaient en
faire une seconde série une seconde
libye et un deuxième irak les arabes et
ce pour des fins malveillantes et
sordide c'est le peuple qui a sauvé son
pays
le irak à sauver l'état algérien de
l'effondrement rollois où un homme
hautain quand je les dérives
autocratiques et des velléités de
perduration de la tragédie politique que
vive l algerie le iraqiya mis fin il
était la base de sa protection par
l'armée nationale et populaire jacques
que le peuple algérien a retrouvé sa
fierté grâce à lui et chante pas très
riche ou pas je me rappelle lorsque
j'étais simple citoyen en dehors du
pouvoir
j'avais les larmes aux yeux quand je
voyais l'image d'un pays comme l'algérie
se marrent soulier profanés dans les
différents pays arabes et européens
l'arabie saoudite en europe et les
années je veux ramener un portrait jour
on se prosterner devant lui la luire aka
stopper ce drame
il a arrêté le cinquième mandat est
annulé la tentative de prolongement du
quatrième mandat ça va deux mots comment
échapper au collet hilare a mené
l'algérie sur son chemin démocratique et
populaire et dans tous les rendez vous
de l'histoire contemporaine at le peuple
était la base y compris les
manifestations des années 60 et 61 qui
ont mené au droit à l'autodétermination
sans appauvrir le rôle des martyrs qui
ont combattu pour ça j'ai sam des jo à
damas bras ou le bouddha et des
réactions
ils ont été soutenus par le peuple qui a
toujours été en cohésion avec ses
dirigeants populaires jamais duncan les
arcanes et armes aux barrages
l'effondrement de l'état algérien
étaient programmés ou atteints sur le
peuple
le miracle a stoppé et a donné l'image
d'un peuple pacifique
j'ai cultivé et politisé sacha loin de
cette image d'un peuple
inconscient et terrorisme comme tenté de
lui donner même certains pays frères
ouah ouah tanit
les algériens ont donné ainsi des leçons
mon guide web un art au chatterton la
ville j'ai notamment quant au caractère
républicain de l'armée nationale
populaire
laquelle a démontré par son patriotisme
quelle était la digne héritière de
l'armée de libération nationale
l'armée assuré la sécurité au mouvement
populaire sans qu'aucune goutte de sang
ne soit versée durant cette année
aujourd'hui les algériens sont cités
comme exemple dans plusieurs pays
même dans ceux qui se considèrent
développer et civilisé ce sont les
principales revendications du miracle
arrêter la mascarade du cinquième mandat
de refuser la prolongation du quatrième
mandat faire tomber les responsables du
régime du président déchu qui ont
programmé l'effondrement de l'état et le
jugement de tous ceux qui ont détruit
l'économie nationale à des fins
personnelles dont la plupart sont
aujourd'hui en prison ce qui reste à
faire c'est de revoir le mode de
gouvernance de ce cher pays avec la
garantie de la plus grande marche
possible aux libertés personnelles ainsi
que d'instaurer lé équilibre entre les
institutions afin d'éviter la domination
de l'une ou de l'autre les intimidations
le dérapage vers le pouvoir exclusif et
l'autoritarisme
nous sommes sur le point de trancher sur
la question
automoto adrena la ouate chèque je vais
revenir avec vous sur votre projet de
révision de la constitution
mais j'aimerais d'abord vous poser une
question sur les algériens qui
continuent d'envahir la rue jusqu'à
maintenant
que leur dites-vous est-ce qu'on attend
la réalisation de toutes ces
revendications
et est ce que ces manifestations qui
persistent constitue une charge sur le
pouvoir surtout sur le volet sécuritaire
ou doit-on nous habituer à cette image
démocratique de l'algérie de l'après 22
février chercher de machault fin à
retrouver personnellement je n'y vois
aucun inconvénient à leur manifestation
c'est leur droit et la démocratie
l'exigera ça ne pose aucun problème
nous craignons juste les dérives
résultant de l'infiltration des rangs du
peuple et je pense que celui-ci est
conscient que lorsqu ils soupçonnent il
engage toute infiltration il sent
démarre line chiche matin pour ce qui en
reste
c'est une question de la liberté
d'expression et de la démocratie dont
nous rêvons tous
par ailleurs entre la majorité et la
minorité
il est connu que dans les pays
démocratiques la majorité priment est
décidé à tout en respectant la minorité
mais lorsque une minorité veut imposer
ses idées sur une majorité démocrate
on se retrouve dans un autre système
différent du système démocratique
choisi par le peuple algérien quand on
passe par des étapes holistique
il peut y avoir parfois une exagération
dans la démocratie mais je pense que
j'aurais petit les gens reprennent
conscience et des manifestations
s'organisent de manière limitée pour des
raisons et avec des slogans spécifiques
nous allons nous y mettre bientôt vous
avez parlé des révisions
constitutionnelles et de la réception de
quelques personnalités et de certains
partis de l'opposition
il y en a qui aperçoivent le changement
différemment en particulier en ce qui
concerne l'établissement des priorités
vous avez choisi de commencer par la
révision de la constitution
et puis la proposer au référendum mais
en passant d'abord par le parlement
celui qui conteste la légitimité du
parlement en parlant de vote truqué dit
qu'il aurait fallu dissoudre le
parlement et organiser des élections
législatives anticipées
je suis trop cédé à la réforme politique
kraton quelles sont les normes que vous
avez adopté pour la définition du
calendrier du changement premièrement b
la logique veut que la construction
d'une maison commence toujours par les
fondations non par le toit il n'est pas
logique que nous commençons par la loi
électorale alors que la constitution n'a
pas encore tranché dans les élections ni
même dans le rôle des élus leur contrôle
et leur pouvoir
thérapeute tableau un attelage h et k en
ce qui concerne l'organisation des
élections avant j'ai expliqué au frère
que j'ai reçu les mêmes raisons
produisent les mêmes effets la
dissolution du parlement et
l'organisation d'élections législatives
dans les conditions actuelles conduira
au même résultat
car l'argent sale je continue à circuler
c'est l'abus de pouvoir existe toujours
et la révéla on aura donc le même
parlement ni avec les mêmes attributs
refusé par certains est acceptée par
d'autres au mort de saulieu outre canal
mais une fois que tous ces aspects
seront définies est régi par la
constitution
et certaines pratiques criminaliser nous
pourrons aller vers un nouveau parlement
dont la majorité des membres seront des
jeunes intellectuels ayant suffisamment
d'autorité morale pour agir en
collaboration avec le gouvernement
ratha et ses héros si les choses se
passent selon le calendrier politique
définie sans passer par des législatives
anticipées
des élections auront lieu dans deux ans
cette période suffira-t-elle pour
réviser la constitution et la loi
électorale que vous avez considéré comme
l'un des piliers de la réforme politique
puis aller vers des élections
transparentes avec de réelles
représentants du peuple et l'ina sur
l'hygiène alléchant beaucoup moins de
deux ans je pensais une période de six
mois nous avons sont trés rapidement
aujourd'hui à la cad bane que certains
de nos frères n'arrive même pas nous
suivre
je n'accepterai pas que les choses
continuent à courir que chef il faut
qu'on rentre dans la phase des solutions
draw lowball le chantier de la révision
constitutionnelle sera achevé au plus
tard d'ici le début de l'été et avant la
fin de l'année nous aurons terminé avec
la constitution et le code électoral
parvenir ainsi aux élections
législatives et locales
[Musique]
c'est à dire qu'il est possible
d'organiser des élections législatives
anticipées avant la fin de l'année arlon
monsieur le président du volet
économique auquel vous consacrez
beaucoup d'intérêt à chaque parution
médiatique
quels sont les importants points à
partir desquels vous partirez et quel
est le modèle économique qu'adoptera
l'algérie lors de votre gouverne à 10 le
nombre de ses chats des nazis ou
nabatian ce sera un modèle économique
honnête et propre sur la mission
principale de l'économie jugé que nous
bâtirons très prochainement là sera la
création de richesses l'agréation
d'emplois et la prise en charge de
toutes les tragédies social qu'a vécu le
citoyen algérien sa de meublés il sera
impératif de sortir de la dépendance à
la rente pétrolière et d'aller vers la
quête d'autres ressources au maroc afin
d'asseoir une économie qui n'est pas axé
sur l'importation
l'algérie est actuellement une sorte de
bazar d'import-export grâce à une
production nationale est inexistante et
ta joie panne et la nouvelle économie
sera fondée sur des bases logiques et
nationalistes une économie profitant aux
pays aux citoyens au chaud et non un
clan d'oligarques roatan et ses sables
des arabes les richesses reviendront
peuple et seront redistribués moche
oligarchie
[Musique]
je voudrais d'abord rebondir sur la
france la dépendance aux hydrocarbures
que vous avez évoqué la ken blackman
certains ont critiqué le passage de la
rente pétrolière au gaz de schiste
le gaz de schiste est l'une des
justifications sur troqué la colère des
citoyens
non je n'ai pas dit qu'on allait
exploiter le gaz de schiste les chiffres
démontrent qu'avec son développement
l'algérie a consommé près de la moitié
de sa production du gaz naturel
sachant que nous sommes un pays plus
riches en gaz quand pétrole ou de même
pour les hydrocarbures
chap si on continue sur ce rythme on
sera peut-être obligé d'importer du gaz
chose qui n'est ni logique ni
raisonnable maroc attaché chez workman
loin de parler de l'exploitation du gaz
de schiste
j'ai dit que dans cette affaire la
décision finale dépend du rapport des
experts
ces derniers diront s'il est rentable ou
pas et polluantes par l'algérie compte
aujourd'hui des richesses
incommensurables dans nos mines par
exemple nous ne manquons d'aucune
ressource en ce qui concerne les
ressources humaines la capacité
universitaire algérienne produit 200
milles universitaire parents comme dans
le secteur de l'agriculture entre le
nord et le sud du pays
nous avons tout le potentiel agricole du
sud n'est pas exploité à seulement 50
mètres au fond de ces agglomérations
nous comptons 15 milliards de mètres
cubes d'eau douce chamame nous avons des
terres immenses qui n'ont jamais
exploité
car nous nous sommes contentés d'un
portée entre fin 2018 et début 2019 à
doit notre agriculture a généré près de
18 milliards de dollars en dépit du
sous-développement et des techniques
traditionnelles sur lesquels repose le
secteur cher notre tâche
si aujourd'hui on développe notre
agriculture et on arrive à générer entre
20 et 22 milliards de dollars de
bénéfices tard entre les attentes en
arrêtant l'importation on arrivera à un
équilibre dans l'économie nationale
le secteur des hydrocarbures resterait
une option pour les générations à venir
le torus le marché économique
alors on est après tout jamais statique
il connaît toujours des hauts et des bas
brad wall a revenons sur la période de
votre absence du pouvoir marquée chez
les algériens par vos déclarations anti
corruption ce qui vous a éloigné du
gouvernement durant les années
précédentes il exactement de l'anarchie
de l'importation du transfert illicite
de capitaux et du marché parallèle des
devises en sarre bas à lahti tout ça me
chante l'hymne cabanasse quelle est
votre stratégie pour venir à terme de
ces pratiques qui portent préjudice à
l'économie nationale
l'italie
marsatac business angels
il faut changer les mentalités
avant tout l'interdît est toujours
désirer et what what may en ce qui
concerne la devise j'ai promis au peuple
algérien d'augmenter le taux de change
touristique ce qui préservera sa dignité
dans les pays étrangers il ne pourra pas
voyager chaque année mais peut-être tous
les deux ans pour ce qui est du square
square port saïd
il a été utilisé pour l'évasion et le
transfert illicite des devises et des
sommes importantes non déclarés vers
l'étrange arabe
ce fléau n'est pas propre à l'algérie
mais il ya de nombreux pays qui s'en
sont remis je sais que c'est dur de
passer de notre situation actuelle c'est
100 à savoir une économie qui nous tenu
par une vérité et l'ardèche à vers une
économie nationale b permettant aux
algériens de vivre dignement
je suis certain qu'on solutionnera ce
fléau d'une manière ou d'une autre je
peux donner l'exemple des citoyens
algériens vivant à l'étranger qui
désirent envoyer de l'argent vers leur
pays
pourquoi leur imposer le change en
dinars les saisons les ouvrir des
comptes devises pour transférer leur
argent légalement sans abus ni
dépassement
cette affaire comme ça excusez moi
monsieur le président mais c'est ce qui
les pousse à adopter des tactiques
illégales et se tourner vers le marché
parallèle sans créer de richesses
quelles sont les solutions auxquelles
vous pensez
lure l'économie qui sera bâti sur la
transparence apportera ses solutions
hh au bloc dans l'économie actuelle
achats toute importation est basé sur le
transfert illicite des capitaux
rawa loi tu en auras paul mas du taureau
mise à part une minorité des
importateurs
le magic le gonflement des factures
thoune a atteint l'intolérable watanwal
et seul le citoyen paie il ya des
mentalités
bâti sur des notions d'une économie
crapuleuses aujourd'hui nous voulons
revenir un secteur transparent avec une
vraie industrie au lieu d'une fausse
industrie basée sur une importation
masquer notre stratégie s'appuie sur
l'indépendance et la responsabilité dans
la prise de décision et demandé la
transparence la création de richesses et
d'emplois qui protégera l'algérie de
toute instabilité politique
les rênes de genève obama sur mana
attaque à l'aube est si le tourisme
pourrait il faire partie de ces
ressources créatrice de richesses
[Musique]
interminable je n'y vois aucun
inconvénient c'est à sourire surtout
pour le tourisme au sahara fait l'album
all aux attentes
nous avons un potentiel unique des
paysages qu'on ne retrouve nulle part
dans le monde
la maquina des amis russes chinois et
tous les touristes du monde ont envie de
visiter nos magnifiques sites
touristiques ne manque que
l'organisation
mais pour le faire il faut laisser
l'initiative aux citoyens et lui
faciliter la tâche
il faut en finir avec les prêts
bancaires
plusieurs milliards de dollars sous
accordés à de faux importateurs au
détriment des jeunes porteurs de projets
touristiques sous prétexte de manque de
garanties puis le temps quelqu'un veut
développer un produit national agricole
mini ou autre on le laisse attendre deux
ans voire trois ans pour lui donner son
prêt alors que 24 heures suffisent à
certains faux producteurs pour la voie
des histoires au dessus et en dessous
des tables existe dans ce genre de
service au chan il est temps aujourd'hui
pour certains de payer les frais de ces
dérapages
mais le plus important c'est d'y mettre
fin au bout d'un char long des jeunes
qui ont déposé des demandes de prêts
pour créer des micro et macro
entreprises et qui ont dû attendre huit
ans ou plus pour avoir une réponse
on m'a évoqué un jour le cas d'un jeune
qui avait déposé une demande de prêts
pour développer une petite industrie de
cassettes audio vaches et sandman
cela remonte à dix ans lorsque celle ci
existait toujours you catch attendus au
cap touché adage à la fin du projet il
s'est retrouvé avec des produits
impossible à écouler jeu dépassés par
l'apparition du numérique
l'injustice existe même quand on veut et
des achats d'or est là pour finir
monsieur le président je voudrais
revenir sur le film documentaire zone
dont andrew ladd a qui suscite beaucoup
de réactions parmi les algériens et que
vous avez partagé avec les oasis en cdi
à moudon josé riga
il y en a qui ont pleuré la situation de
défaillance qui règne dans ces régions
isolées ce prométhée vous aux simples
citoyens qui garde espoir en vie et qui
attend beaucoup de votre gouvernement
la vie est ce qu un mandat de cinq ans
pour construire l'algérie dont on rêve
on lit et jean lacaba ou l'allemande
herta cutter au nar
le documentaire montre la réalité que je
connais les eaux
j'ai passé toute ma vie comme
responsable local
j'ai été secrétaire général ou niqab
wali ministre délégué dans des régions
reculées où je me suis habitué aux
images de ces régions délaissées qui
n'intéressait personne
ce manager personnellement j'ai foi en
la campagne pour de nombreuses raisons
qui sont en grande partie story la
campagne algérienne a' a subi gros
pendant la colonisation
aucune ville n'a été bombardés rostam
ifri l'orece et ouarsenis ce tous leurs
villages ont été saccagés elles ont
ensuite été lié après l'indépendance
même pendant la décennie noire
70% des victimes étaient des ruraux et
on continue à les oublier
pourtant les habitants de cette
agglomération sont des algériens et
bénéficient de tous les droits
je ne demande à aucun responsable de
faire de ces villages des villes mais de
préserver leur dignité et sa bo où on
est né au milieu des chiffres du
développement et du progrès économique
des zones d'ombré existent toujours
cela existe même aux états unis où
l'essor est immense ballon il reste
toujours entre 30 40 et 50 millions
d'américains qui subsiste grâce aux
poubelles
à quoi sert la richesse d'un pays
ses habitants vivent dans la précarité à
mali concrètement comment peut-on
réaliser ce rapprochement du simple
citoyen des boucheleurs mouche à trois
échelons l'oiseau ce n'est nul le
président ou le ministre qui vont s'en
charger mais ça sera la mission du
responsable local
surveillé et contrôlé de près aux
amateurs une commission d'inspection
sera installé au niveau de la présidence
dans ce but m'a cette commission mobile
se déplacera à travers le pays pour
établir des rapports audiovisuel de ce
qui a été réglé ou pas des problèmes de
ces régions reculées
l'opération a déjà commencé en l'espace
de deux mois
des communes ont bénéficié de prêts de
80 milliards de dinars et atteindront
les 100 milliards de dinars d'ici un
mois
cette somme suffit largement pour leur
mission
je donne un exemple il n'est plus
possible de relayer une maison isolée au
courant électrique traditionnelle la
solution actuelle mais plutôt de lui
installer un quai d'énergie solaire
ce kit est entre 25 et 30 millions de
centimes
ce n'est rien devant le confort qu'il
peut apporter à une famille une somme
pareille peut être dépensés sur un
simple anniversaire ailleurs il met la
double avant de conclure que voudriez
vous dire monsieur le président aux
algériens et à tous les spectateurs de
werther à bichat l'idée a atteint à
petit je remercie d'abord tous ceux qui
ont suivi cette interview
chaque je vous remercie vous et vos
équipes pour cette rencontre qui a servi
à mettre la lumière sur notre programme
auprès des nombreux spectateurs de la
chaîne russia today en russie ailleurs
chercheur
je souhaite beaucoup de courage à cette
chaîne
note aux noms barbares et j'en profite
pour saluer honorablement des
fraternellement tous mes amis oui à
notre tour de vous remercier pour votre
chaleureux accueil monsieur le président
de la république algérienne démocratique
et populaire
abdelmadjid t bourny chers
téléspectateurs
nous vous remercions aussi au revoir
[Musique]